[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour
i'm actually really loving the topic
that we're going to be talking about
today
self-care vulnerability and real talk
with tara schuster
i think this is a topic that's really
sailing and important for all of us i
know definitely for me with everything
uh that i have going on with the
challenges that come on a daily basis i
think for all of us as a society this is
just something that's really important
and relevant to all of us
so i'm honored to be able to welcome
tara on the program today
for any who do who don't know her i'm
going to give you just a little bit of
an introduction
um tara is a best-selling author and
playwright
she's also an accomplished and seasoned
entertainment executive
she served as the vice president of
talent and development and comedy
central
where she was the executive in charge of
two emmy-winning shows
key and peel and at midnight in 2020 she
also released the book
buy yourself the effing lilies which
debuted at number one
in humor essays and self-help on albo
and kindle
and was also considered by many
magazines as one of the best
new books in 2020. so again i'm deeply
honored to be able to welcome tara
shuster to the program today thanks so
much for being here
thanks for having me dr addie i'm i'm
thrilled to have this conversation with
you
well definitely looking forward to it
and just knowing your work and the the
conversations that you've had over the
years
your book your upcoming book as well i
think this is just going to be a great
conversation and topic a lot of our
listeners will really be able to engage
with as well
um so as you know as our listeners know
i always like to start with a check in
so just wanted to start there and just
see how you're doing these days in the
midst of everything
uh that we're all dealing with as a
society and just the things they're even
you know walking through in your in your
personal life as well yeah
it's a lot of ups and downs i
can't lie you know and i i would
honestly question
anybody who's not feeling some amount of
ups and downs and
you know my hope and my own growth is to
find equanimity at some point
but i don't got that at this exact
moment um so you know
that said i am finding myself
um better and better able
not to be trapped in my own thought
loops and
stories and anxieties and
and by becoming better at accepting them
accepting that they are just what is
happening and that that's not bad
it doesn't make me bad it doesn't make
all my healing off or not like it's not
some catastrophe it just
kinda is the more and more i get
comfortable with that
the easier and easier it is to loosen
the grip and then all of a sudden i'm
not in some like
anxiety spiral so i'd say
ups and downs but overall actually a lot
more resilient to
the different moods my brain and
emotions
can fling me into and and so
yeah mixed bag i appreciate that honesty
and i think it's interesting that you
put those two together
too because you talked about you know
the honesty of accepting that they're
there
but then also still trying to build
resilience at the same time so it's not
like you're just accepting and saying oh
well right
that's just the way it is and right that
can be done about it
what i find is if i if i don't accept
it if i resist it then i really suffer
then it then it has a texture of
something like
really that's pulling me under but when
i just say oh it is what it is
and that's not my entire life that's
just this
one little slice and that has become
a richer and richer way to just calm
down
because the circumstances outside are
crazy like even
even though the pandemic seems to be you
know in a better place than it was
like what does that even mean a better
place
in a global pandemic of death and
destruction
like this is kind of a worst case
scenario so
you know um just trying to be a little
cut myself a little slack for the fact
that i'm not 100
every single day yeah yeah i mean that
seems so healthy a lot of ways and i
mean you put it in great perspective too
i mean the pandemic
is still going down it's better but it's
not as if we're completely
yeah so there's still yeah like it's
good
for a global pandemic yeah like that's
not a real phrase like when would you
have ever
said that before like oh i'm doing good
for being in a global pandemic yeah
like that's crazy yeah but yeah at the
same time or i know i'm talking like
that a lot of us we're just
all talking that way so it's just kind
of the reality too
and i think you know within the pandemic
even this idea that you've talked about
about acceptance it seems like there's a
lot more acceptance of how anxiety
provoking this has been
across the board i mean other situations
i've said in some ways we've almost gone
through a global trauma
just in terms of not knowing exactly how
things would play out and
all the anxiety that comes with that so
i think for a lot of people who may not
have been able to relate
as well to anxiety beforehand this
became somewhat of an equalizer
because it also heightened some of the
disparities were already there but in
the sense that
you know globally we're kind of dealing
with this uncertainty anxiety i think
that's been
huge for us as a society um but even
with the you know the idea of acceptance
why do you think
even though maybe it's easier for people
to accept now why do you think it's just
so difficult for us to accept
when things are actually challenging i
mean it seems like it's taboo we can't
talk about it we pretend that
right like we're yeah it's
fine it's a funny thing and it's
something i'm writing about you know
like
when you're in line at a grocery store
and there's like a woman behind you and
she's
in tears completely upset and you're
like are you okay and she's like i'm
fine
you're like i'm pretty sure you're not
fine
and like it's pretty weird that our gut
reaction is just deny deny deny
i'm fine distance from this and i think
there are a couple things going on
i think on the societal level
um you know and i particularly in
america we have this
the individual the lone individual who's
like gonna do it on their own
and when we sell ourselves that myth and
we're supposed to be so
strong and never ask for help and then
you know i my book is half memoir half
self-help
and i remember when i was talking to the
marketing people and they told me
well it's going to be in the self-help
category i was like ew
i don't want to be a self-help writer
like that's so cheesy and gross and
terrible and lame
and i really had to check myself of why
is it bad
to help yourself yeah like the people
who have the power to pick up a
self-help
book should be lauded like those are the
powerful strong people who
are taking a step back and saying i have
an issue and i'm strong enough
to deal with it so i think we're fed a
bunch of lies about our
how we need to do things alone i think
that's one part
and i and then the other part i think is
we use
terms like i'm fine i'm okay when we're
genuinely not
so that we can distance ourselves from
what's real like
it's a dif i think a defense mechanism a
lot of the time
um to reject the reality reject the pain
i'm fine moving on i don't want to talk
about it
and it also gives everyone in our lives
cover because then
they don't have to be intimate with our
problems either we can and
and then they don't have to face their
own issues that our issues might
kick up and it just puts us all in a
terrible position because then
everybody's lying
like nothing is true and people feel
like they can't
reach out and ask for help because they
don't think anybody else is experiencing
what they're experiencing
because what we're fed is that we should
all just be fine
yeah so that's sort of my take on
why we default to i'm fine which also by
the way is so lame like i don't want to
live my life as
fine true it's so sad yeah
yeah yeah that's so important i think
you know like you said it just leaves
i mean it leaves the stigma in place too
um some of our earlier episodes we were
talking with an nfl player he was
saying some of the same types of things
in terms of nobody want to talk about it
everybody going through it themselves
but once you get everyone in the room
actually talking about it
and they're all like realizing that
they're all dealing with the same thing
they thought they were the only one
then so yeah this collective group
theory
therapy type of moment where people can
actually walk through things together
and actually learn from each other so i
think that's so totally right
and i think we're kind of in a societal
group therapy moment
you know that and and you know there's
great disparities about what kinds of
suffering and
what disadvantages people have and you
know there's a lot packed in with
within that but if you are a human on
planet earth
currently our current circumstances are
not ideal
so to at some point it's to some extent
everybody is kind of
being confronted with this and and i
think you know even having
publicly athletes um like the football
player you mentioned or you know this
week um
the tennis player and the french open
dropping out for her own mental health
like having examples of people saying
like hey wait
my mental health is my priority without
that there's nothing
else i mean this wouldn't have happened
two years ago
yeah you know exactly right people were
not this open
so i think it might be an unintended
good consequence
of the pandemic is just it ripped off
so much of the artifice and so much of
the like
everything is fine we just you know
patchworked over this whole thing and
doesn't it look nice and it's like no
it doesn't it's the insides are rotten
exactly
yeah and i mean i noticed even the
timing of your book released too i mean
i'm sure you weren't predicting that and
potentially plan to release a book
during the pandemic but how do you think
that affected
like how it was received do you think
that was yeah ty in there
i'm i 100 i mean you know obviously
you work so hard on a book you know in
some ways that book took me 30 years to
write
you know it took three dedicated
years but 30 of thinking about the book
and i was supposed to go on like a big
book tour and
bought a dress to wear and like that
dress is still
sitting in my closet a year and a half
later like who knows when i'm gonna wear
that dress
so that was different that was an
adjustment and that
had its own amount of grief um for me
because it wasn't how i pictured things
going and it wasn't what i expected and
the book coming out in the pandemic was
the perfect time for this exact message
because people desperately needed
some with so much structure taken out of
their lives
it was actually the perfect time to
build in some good habits
and everything in my book you know my
book is about self-care and how to bring
small rituals into your life that help
you
enjoy your life and be present for it um
people had time to try these things you
know
even if you you know for example if you
weren't commuting to the office anymore
that meant you had 20 minutes to journal
um
and and because everything in my book is
free or super low cost
there were also just no barriers to
entry there
and and it helped that the book was sold
in target so while you were like
grabbing all your toilet paper and beans
you could pick up this pretty book with
a you know flowers on it
yeah and and so in this really
messed up way it was the perfect time
for this book to come out and i think i
probably reached a much
broader audience than i otherwise would
have
and i don't i'm not happy that
you know who's releasing it like i don't
i'm not like the kind of person who
needs to look for silver linings and
everything
i just think both things are true like
you know it was
sad that it happened in a way that i
didn't expect and it
amazing and wonderful and i've been able
to connect with so many people
and hopefully be helpful in a time
where i would really want to be helpful
like this is the time to serve your
community
if not now then when you know yeah yeah
so important so i mean the investment i
think is so worthwhile for
so many people um and even you know as
you're talking through
through this i'm just curious to you
about how you even got yourself to that
place of putting a book together
especially with your initial kind of
reaction to the whole self-care mode and
to get into a place of i mean the way
you're talking now really wanting to
invest in people
in the community and kind of empower
people like how did that transition
happen
yeah um so i guess for me
i never set out to write a book like
that was not on my mind
i set out to save my life um the
origins of the book were i grew up
in a neglectful psychologically abusive
household where things came to die
you know my first memory is of a family
of deer
dying in our lap pool and me seeing
their water lot
carcasses on a blue tarp you know i was
like probably five
and it was just an unsafe place to grow
up
chaos constant screaming
from my parents um and
i didn't have any role models of like no
one was taking care of me
they weren't taking care of them there
was just no
thought that maybe it would be important
to take care of yourself
and so i really used external
achievement as a way to get myself
out of that house you know i was the
teacher's pet doing the extra credit
extracurricular
literary magazine ap's award award award
you know
hustle hustle hustle this one this will
save me like work will save me
um and in a funny way it kind of did
because
it got me to brown you know which was
like a fancy ivy league school that put
like a nice stamp on me
which helped me get my first entry-level
job at comedy central
and i just kept hustling and working and
going
and because that's all i knew how to do
but in the inside
i was utterly imploding i was living in
a
permanent panic attack where my um
jaw would clench down so hard that like
i understood what the term gnashing of
teeth meant like it created like a
chronic migraine which then i had to
take
other medication for um
and then i would self-medicate with weed
and booze and boys
and just trying to distract because i
had no interior life
like there wasn't there was no there
there i didn't know who i was i was lost
and i might have kept just going that
way had i not
hit rock bottom on my 25th birthday when
i drunk dialed my therapist
and threatened to hurt myself and for me
that morning
the morning after when i was listening
to voicemails from her and kind of
piecing together
oh my god i you know i'm in trouble like
i could have killed myself like my
therapist who was like a very
rational calm you know vaguely european
woman who always just had on a scarf and
a little cup of tea
like she was worried and that was the
first time i got worried
so that morning i just decided okay i
don't have parents
i i don't have like a wise mentor to go
to
but i do have my hustle like i do have
this thing in me that's always trying to
achieve
so what if i made a google doc
of how to re-parent myself like what if
i tried
like and i i just wrote in the google
doc it started with just questions i had
like what are values what are principles
what are vegetables like genuinely like
what vegetables should i be eating right
now what is quinoa is that a vegetable
the answer is no
um like so
it's an ancient grain um so it was
really even that basic
like do i need to be drinking water yes
like like would making my bed be a good
idea
hell yes like very basic things like
that but then
much bigger things like confronting why
i'm
why am i in the same romantic
relationship over and over and over
again and why am i
so comfortable when other people make me
feel uncomfortable or make me feel small
like why is that
so familiar and so i did this for five
years
and at the end of five years i had a 600
page google document
i felt like a completely different
person i felt
stable you know i wasn't self-medicating
i wasn't running away from my life i was
living it
and that's when i decided i have an
offering
i have something to share with other
people i wish someone had shared
their journey with me that would have
been helpful
and as i wrote that book and
i i realized oh i have all these like
tricks too
like because just from my google doc i
would have like a list
like i started listing what makes me
feel good
like i really started noticing this is
what makes me feel good and
these are the questions that help me in
my journal and
you know um this is how exercising
affects my body and my brain
so i just had all these lists um that i
thought might be helpful to somebody
else
and so they just were
became a part of the stories to me and
once i realized it was useful um
then i kind of got over my initial oh i
don't want to be a self-help writer
because i'm like
wait why every author who's
ever lived if their book made you feel
less alone was a self-help author in
some way they reached out your hand and
said you belong
and they do it in their own way and i
just wanted to be more explicit
um because i would have appreciated if
someone had been more explicit with me
so that's sort of i just wanted to be of
use and of service so that's how i got
over
the sort of my initial disdain of
self-help right well i appreciate you
yes yeah through that journey i mean
there's so much there too
yeah i'm just impressed by the level of
introspection that you had too
to be able to and diligence to go
through that process i think a lot of us
would have just
gotten tired of that process to be
completely honest and been like
i can't do this anymore so the fact that
you're able to kind of keep going i mean
it sounds like you were seeing
would you say you were seeing things
change along the way or was it oh yeah
specific moment
that all every step was like a brand new
life
was being born and i i really want to be
clear that
i wasn't pumped to do this i wasn't like
yay this is going to be so fun and not
hard
i mean there were many times where i was
just like why
why do i have to work so hard at this
like why do i
everybody else like this is when i get
really self-pity
which i definitely have in me i'm like
why is everybody else just get to live
their life and like here i am with this
stupid google document
like charting how many drinks of alcohol
work for me like why am i even doing
this
and why i was even doing this was i
wanted to be healthy yeah
you know at the bottom of everything it
was like well it was for my own health
and so i just kept going
and i think the thing i was born with
that you know if you believe in god or
the universe or whatever
is i was born with a soul that wanted to
be healthy
and i don't really have to feed it much
more than that like it just wants
to be healthy it just wants to be free
and so
when i get tired of this stuff i just
lean back
on the truth of me which is i want to be
liberated
i want to i want to be healthy and let
that
energy carry me yeah well that's so bad
was that too woo-woo
did i just know that was way over that
was definitely good and now i appreciate
you uh
talking about the struggle too because i
feel like that's you know that's half of
it
it like it doesn't help us when we only
hear about the victory on the other side
but to know that
like you're like this is not exciting
it's painful
but i've got to do it and like you had
this internal
god-given drive to just keep going
i mean the whole preface to my second
book which i'm working on right now
and it will be way cut down but is a
greatest hits of my complaints about why
do i have to do this
i've it's never been like oh this is
easy and so
fun like if you're listening to this
you're like man
it's a struggle to face my life as it
really is
and heal myself you are correct yeah
it is a struggle and it is really hard
and you can bear it because you already
are
whatever you've been through is already
dealing with you so it's just an
opportunity that you can
choose your reaction it's just like a
slight shift like it's a different kind
of suffering it's a suffering
i enjoy more yeah i guess that makes a
lot of sense
i mean in some ways you know as you're
talking to it seems like there's
parallels too
to the way that you approached your work
before that too because i mean you
basically stayed on your grind
you made sure you knew what you had to
do you did it but with this it's the
same type of thing and we don't always
think about that way
when we're dealing with emotional
challenges sometimes it's easy to just
feel like oh i wish this was just fixed
even though we knew like deep down i
think we know we still got to put in
that work
but just doesn't come naturally you're
exactly right
it's you know when we have a work
project and we're like i need you that
you know we think about it rationally
like goal like here's the small goal
then this and it'll lead to this and
that's how i'll achieve this
but then take a thing like generosity
like
i want to be more generous we just are
like and magically that will happen
somehow or i want to have a better
relationship with my mom
and magically like and time will do that
no it's not time
it's work just like every other thing in
life it's work
we can all do work so we can all we can
all achieve this and that is the message
of my book is
there is no special reason that i should
have been able to re-parent myself
i'm not i'm not i'm special in certain
ways that's not how
how i'm special it was just sticking
to doing work and having a little
a little faith that i was worth it and
that i could do it
yeah yeah i think that's so good i mean
and you're reaping the benefits and then
helping so many people at the same time
i mean again like such a process it
sounds like to get there
because i even heard you talk about you
know ways you felt like you're really
good at work but bad at life
yeah you had to really like come to
terms with that
yeah and again it goes back to that that
whole idea of just being honest with
ourselves i mean like okay this
aspect of life needs work and i can't
just leave it and expect it to all of a
sudden
fix itself it's honesty and
self-awareness
i mean those are the keys to
having a life that doesn't feel like
happening to you
you know it's it's and it takes a lot to
to look at yourself and all of your
flaws and say like well this just
is really me you know but i what i've
found
is in it you know and getting back to
acceptance just accepting that gives me
so many
options like i have options now to
change
if i want to and there are some things
about me i don't want to change like
i'm an extremely trusting person often
to my own
detriment i don't want to change that
about me
like i like that i like that because it
opens me up to a lot of
possibility and it's painful because
you know that's a living with your heart
on your shoulders
just can be a little painful and
i can handle that well you know what i
i'm i'm
doing it currently so so i do think it's
that honest accounting of where we
really are and being self-aware enough
to know
and i can change this with some work
like it's not just going to magically
hit me one day
yeah yeah i think that's so well said
i'm also curious because there's so many
topics i feel like resonate with a lot
of people just how people
have responded to the book itself
because one of the pieces that i feel
like you've highlighted really well
is just how how easy it is to be
dismissive
of any challenges and just to think well
so-and-so has it worse than me which
could be true it's often true
and then kind of look back at ourselves
and be like oh i shouldn't be struggling
because i mean i've seen that a lot
during the pandemic like any specific
individual that i talk to
whatever their circumstance is they feel
bad they're struggling because they can
pick out someone else who's doing worse
and they feel like well i shouldn't be
struggling
right they are struggling so they can't
get as much done or they're struggling a
certain area and they feel anxious and
depressed because they can't
move that maybe not clinical depression
per se but that loophole
right definitely starts to kick in
pretty early so
i'm curious if you have people talked
with you about that as they've been
reading through your books they're ways
that you've tried to even move
past that kind of reaction in your own
life yeah i mean
absolutely and and you're hitting on i
think one of the
biggest things that i've found because
for so long
i didn't want to heal because i didn't
have it that bad
i should be better and i'm doing massive
air quotes
and what i kind of realized was that was
not beneficial
for people for other people who perhaps
were
suffering more for me like me minimizing
my experience
didn't help them and it certainly wasn't
helping me
so just who in the world was i
dismissing myself for
and once i kind of like saw that kind of
clearly i realized
this isn't helpful this isn't productive
i gotta reframe this
and um the writer lori gottlieb who
wrote maybe you should talk to someone
and she's one of my absolute
favorite writers thinkers everything
she talks about in her book this theory
of um there's no hierarchy of pain
there really isn't nobody's pain
is any more valid than anyone else's
because it's real like you can like
you're talking about your friends or
someone who
they're denying their own suffering
because it's not a worst case scenario
that doesn't mean it isn't still painful
for them
and that that isn't their absolute
reality and so again if we deny what is
real
then we can't deal with anything so the
i often ask myself what would the wisest
version of me
how how would the wisest version of me
handle this situation
i call it future tara like what how
would future tara
handle this you know because i don't
have all this wisdom now
but like in the future maybe so like how
would she deal with this
and often it's i wouldn't dismiss
myself i wouldn't call myself stupid and
silly i wouldn't
demean myself i would look at the actual
circumstances
and try to help myself try to resource
myself
and deal with them so that they did not
deal with me
and so readers have really picked up on
this and they've talked a lot about
feeling like
they didn't have the quote-unquote worst
childhood ever
and that because it wasn't you know on
the news
level bad they never dealt with it but
now they see that it's dealing with them
and that they have to go back
and and do some work and confront these
things
that they actually are confronting every
single day
so yeah i've really seen that people
kind of being
um pausing and denying
their actual experience yeah and i think
that's great just to get
to get people to realize that because
that's that's half i don't sound like gi
joe half the battle but it also shows my
age
no it is and it's also like people still
having trouble with it like it's also
condescending to think
of other people as much much worse like
who are you to even
like the whole thing is so backwards and
weird that it's like
better if you can just however you need
to move off of it just like let's just
move off
of that idea yeah yeah and even the way
that you're i mean the way that you're
inspiring so many people too i mean
another topic that we talk about a lot
and i know we talked about this
you know offline before too just that
whole balance between
helping yourself versus helping other
people yeah
and just the danger of ignoring our own
challenges and trying to help other
people i mean that's also come up
another podcast
uh before with other psychologists that
have come on you know as us being
healers the healers can't help heal
if they're not going through that
healing process too so how do you
balance that
in your own life i mean with this
explosion of support that you're giving
wow you know you still have your own
life to kind of walk through too
it's been um an unexpected
little bit of an adjustment because
i don't because i'm still in process
like
and the thing about my my book and my
writing is like
i don't know all the answers i'm not an
expert like
i don't have a single degree in any of
the things i'm talking about
what i am is a little sponge like i just
sponge in
everything i can learn and then i try to
apply it in a real way
that i i think is relatable to other
people because i can really break it
down
yeah so that's what i am i'm not the one
who did the research i'm not the one who
like
has your degree and is at yale um
so what i've really had so so i've
really had to kind of
say to myself is and i don't know i'm
trying to still really figure it out is
how can i be the most helpful i know
what feels the best
the the best feelings i have are when
i'm
writing the book like when i'm really
really trying to be honest
and the work connects with people
i like when i speak to a bigger crowd
and that feels really good i like
when i talk one-on-one with somebody if
i just like meet them
but constantly being in my dms or
replying to every single email even
though these messages are
utterly beautiful you know and even
though people are gracing me with the
hardest moments of their lives if i
do every single one i can't write i
can't go
speak to a bigger group i so i myself
because i'm so i cr
i crave connection given that i had none
growing up you know and i felt so alone
like one of my driving forces is a
feeling of connection
and so i'm having to figure out how do i
connect
how do i help in a way that i'm not
completely depleted and so that i can
continue the work
yeah so it's really like an open
question i i don't know the answer
um i gen i have no idea
i'm just still trying to kind of figure
it out for myself it's a process in the
journey
i mean if i'm being completely honest i
feel like i'm on that journey in some
ways too
i mean you must be in particular because
we talked a little
offline too about how even in your in
your profession like professionally
your job is to help but then does it
become
everyone coming to you to kind of like
fix or you know explain to them what's
going on and does that feel
like such a response like i could
imagine that feeling
both like an honor you know this person
has come to me
but also wait wait wait like i need to
maintain some boundaries
yeah yeah so i mean i think even for me
it's something i'm still
walking through and figuring out on a
day-to-day basis
um because like you said each of those
conversations can be so personal
and touching and and empowering in a
sense too
but then knowing how much to engage in
those
versus you know there's a lab research
that we do there's this podcast
obviously right so you know i still have
to eat and sleep
like how do you balance that and not
spread yourself so thin
that you become completely ineffective
for everyone so i mean i appreciate the
way you're sharing that and i'd say in a
lot of ways
you know i wouldn't say i've arrived in
that place but some of it's just having
folks who couldn't look into and kind of
watch and say okay
i think you're getting a little bit
spread thin here is there anything else
back
on that's interesting who can i ask you
a question
yeah yeah i got to flip the script for a
second
who in your life asks you that question
like hey are you spread too thin
yeah so i'd say some of it is just like
going to people in faith communities
so a pastor that i'm pretty close with
who has basically been
in this journey we did an event together
back in 2019 called god mental health
and wellness in new york city
and so having him just kind of interject
and check in and see how things are
going opportunities and just
you know sometimes not even having to
ask the question but knowing me well
enough
to be able to kind of sense and ask
questions that will get me to that place
yeah and sometimes to be honest it's
just uh even just acquaintances or
or not even acquaintances but colleagues
that i know really well
when we sit down and talk about all the
different initiatives that are going on
the research
i'm also doing a lot of work around
diversity equity inclusion anti-racism
there's a podcast there's informal
mentoring so people are asking are you
taking i mean someone asked me last week
are you taking enough time for yourself
i said it's a strategic process some
days are better than others and then you
know you balance in i mean i'm i have
i'm married i have kids as well so you
put all that in the mix so to be honest
like to me when someone asks that kind
of point of question
it's challenging frustrating and
refreshing
because that's really when i have the
opportunity to check myself
and say yeah well is this actually true
why am i getting to a point where this
is just not sustainable so
well it's so important to have people in
your life who like truly know you
in in that way to even ask the question
and that they're not afraid to ask like
is this too much
um i often silence those people you know
they i have a couple of people in my
life who are like you're doing
what now and what now and what now is
that too much i'm like
i can handle it like don't put me down
um but when i can be not defensive and
not a jerk
and hear the question it's always yeah
you're doing way too much
like you need you need to find a metal
gear
and i accept that except i'm this is a
place where i'm processing and trying to
figure out like
what's my middle gear yeah yeah well i
appreciate you asking honestly
and asking the question too yeah i was
gonna get there but you made me pulled
out even more than i probably would have
so
you're very skilled in that sense my
trick yeah
i mean i think i think it's so so
important a lot of ways because it's so
easy for us to just
in several ways just just spread too
thin and not
be about almost like we're being about
too much at once
i've talked to some uh some people just
in terms of even just
uh professionally people saying well you
know you're gonna have to say no
sometimes and you're gonna feel guilty
about that yeah
but you actually just kind of have to
deal with it oh i'm so bad
and just think about where your
priorities are so i think that's another
place that it takes some time to get
there and i think the pandemic has kind
of hastened
the idea that we need to
stick to our priorities you know i think
a lot of people what they saw
is you know maybe going to like 50
weddings
and constantly out of town and
work work work work wasn't making me
happy
and was it like weird own priority
and isn't actually in line with what my
real priorities are
or for a lot of people it was the first
time they asked themselves what are my
priorities
yeah but are they even and i really hope
that coming out of the
pandemic we can re
retain some sense of our priorities
of who we are and how we want how we
want to carry ourselves in the world
and then follow through so
you know i remember before the pandemic
like always being on a work trip
complaining to my friends about how much
i had to travel
and now i look back i'm like what a jerk
like
wasn't even looking at it as the
gratitude for
wow i get to go to cool places was so
jaded
that i'm like complaining and who did
that benefit because i wasn't enjoying
it
and the people i was like flying to
their
bachelorette in tulum or whatever you
know whatever the detail was
you know people know and you don't want
to be somewhere yeah
yeah it's not like you're fooling
everybody like
we all we're all smart like we know
yeah uh you know the woman who you like
have grudgingly agreed to go to lunch
with like as you check your watch
she doesn't feel like seen
so you know even with things like
people are starting to ask like can you
go to coffee again
like you know i'm vaccinated you know
other fully vaccinated people
and i'm like do i really want to go to
coffee
because i don't think i do so now what
you know i'm really like i'm just in
real time
staying my my issues right now yeah
so i mean in some ways it sounds like
you're like you're re-prioritizing too
i think a lot of people have done that
especially the way you talked about your
trips
too yeah definitely i have to do this
after this and i know you've talked
about that before to shift into i get to
do this
yeah i mean i think for even me
personally a lot of us those trips now
feel like a luxury
like oh wow if i were gonna do that
right now just a whole
different perspective on things i'm kind
of scared
to be honest like i have i haven't flown
yet
i haven't i don't have any real like big
trips planned i'm and i used to travel
all of the time and i love traveling
um and now i'm just kind of scared i'm
scared of my life getting out of control
i don't want to ever go back to the
place where i wasn't prioritizing
the things that really matter to me and
the pandemic
i was fortunate to be in a situation
where i got to
focus on the things that mattered to me
and
it's almost like a drug addict you know
and like
i'm seeing like and now i'm in the room
again with all the things that used to
you know get me high or whatever and for
me it's like travel distraction
constant plans planning doing those are
my
um that's my drug of choice
and so i'm a little afraid like i'm
actually a little afraid
yeah how are you going to re-engage i
mean do you have
between that and just like your daily
self-care like how how do you plan
to step back into the world or is that
still a process you're figuring out
i think it's saying no more
like doing a lot less doing the things i
actually want to do um
and baby stepping you know i'm gonna
take my first
trip um with two of my best friends
we're gonna do a one
overnight one night overnight by the
beach
this weekend you know that feels like a
good small
yeah start small start incrementally
remember the big picture which is
i don't want to over plan again i i
don't need to distract myself from my
life
not everything has to be an achievement
and even working it into my everyday
schedule so that
i have more breaks you know
even when i'm writing that i write by
timing myself
so i have like a timer and i when the
timer goes off after an hour
i'm free and i so then i get up i dance
to one song
and then i sit back down it's my second
hour but it's that little break
you know that little time to enjoy
and not to produce and not make anything
yeah so i'm trying to i'm really trying
to
bake into my life the habits of what my
actual priorities are
as opposed to um
just get back into the swing of things
as soon as i
possibly can right right yeah i
appreciate you kind of walking us
through that in real time and i think
that's so
i mean i love the just the incremental
steps and just kind of re-engaging
i mean in a lot of ways like everything
you're talking about is self-care too
and yeah i mean in some ways when you're
talking about future tara it's like
you're
anticipating what you'll learn and
trying to teach that to yourself now
so yeah and continue to move forward
which i think is great or to
i i think it's really to give future
tara the resources
she needs because i'm not smart enough
i don't know i don't know like what
she's going to learn
i'm not a fortune teller but like i can
feel out what resources that person i
might
want to be needs and
and i can give her that i can make
choices today you know
and that is self-care because that's
everything that's like
so i can go for a run you know i don't
know ultimately am i going to lose a
little weight am i not i don't know
but i can go on this run that's how i
eat you know what's this all gonna mean
in the future i don't know
but i can eat more fruits and vegetables
i definitely can do that
and it's even like very practical things
like
um around fertility like i just went
through an egg retrieval process
which was a whole other topic but i
definitely did that for the future
version of myself to have
more options um so i think one really
good self-care
tip is thinking about
what will you want to be possible for
yourself in the future
and what resources can you give that
version of yourself today because then
you'll bet
you you benefit from that in the present
and you benefit from that in the future
yeah that's so good
i really love that perspective and just
the way that you're carrying that out
on a daily basis in a lot of ways and i
mean the way you're sharing that with us
too
so definitely towards that peace on that
note i'm curious just even about and
you've talked about this already but
just legacy
like what are you trying i know it's a
sometimes we don't
think about that at a younger age but i
think you know just with the type of
work
you're doing i'm just curious if that's
something that you've thought through
and what what you're trying to uh
to leave for others in a sense yeah i
oddly try to think about it every day
and i don't use the word legacy but i do
think about
when i'm dead and it's my funeral what
do i want said about me
like what what's the impact i wanted to
have on other people's lives
and am i living in accordance with that
and
i think the most important thing is i i
want to be remembered as somebody
who saw other people who made other
people feel like they belonged
who made other people feel less lonely
and who really
thought and held other people
you know and that would be a life well
lived
is if i was a thoughtful
passenger here and and and
so it's definitely that's like the big
one
and then the second thing i think about
is i
want to show gratitude for the fact that
i ever got to live
by enjoying this time and not making it
like
a constant struggle and a crisis to
endure
but really luxuriating in the details of
a sunny day in los angeles where i got
to take a run
and feel sweat on my body and i got to
talk to you dr addie and that
is actually magical like that's lucky
that's cool
my act of gratitude is to actually enjoy
it
and not just let it like wash over me
not let my life just like rush away
um so those are the so i really do think
about it quite often and i encourage
other people to really think about
what do you want said about you you know
like
it's morbid but it's also very freeing
because you then realize
oh i have a lot of say in that it's
not some magic again it's not some
magical mystery it's
you got to do the work yeah wow that's
that's so good
i mean thriving in a sense as you're
talking about not just
not just being but really thriving yeah
first but you know having you know
having that impact and caring for those
around you
i i get the sense just in talking to you
and then from everything you talked
about with your book i feel like you're
definitely fulfilling that purpose in a
lot of ways in a lot of people's lives
so
definitely appreciate appreciate you you
want to hear about the new book at all
or is that that premature do you want to
uh it's a little early but i'm but i'm
very excited
to that i get to write another book
that's very exciting to me
um yeah well said well definitely
appreciate you taking the time to
share your journey with us i'm impressed
that you pulled some of that out of me
too
i think that was well done but you had
just you know
so much here and i i just really
appreciate the realness and you know
you talking through how you got to this
point what you're kind of trying to do
to go through on a daily basis and i
think
there's so many lessons that all of us
can learn just in walking through this
life with you you know vicariously
through your book through these
engagements and things like that so
definitely appreciate you sharing and
taking time to jump on the addi hour
today yeah well thank you for having me
and thank you for such a
thoughtful conversation and for sharing
yourself because
i know that's not easy to really share
and i really appreciate that you did
yeah i appreciate you asking the
question all right thanks so much tara
thank you